[Music]
so I think something almost everybody
can relate to is the mismatch some that
we all experience between objective time
and subjective time so everybody's
familiar with this notion that time
flies having fun or a watched pot never
boils when you're tightly engaged in a
task or where you're doing something
that you find enjoyable time we say time
seems to fly by which means that your
internal clock is probably going a bit
slower than external an external clock
because you're surprised that maybe an
hour has elapsed an external time but
your internal clock is telling you no
maybe only 15 minutes have gone by now
in order to understand that it's very
important for us to distinguish between
two types of timing one we call
prospective timing and when we call
retrospective timing so this relates to
something called the vacation paradox so
maybe you're on vacation here in Athens
for the first time during the day you're
experiencing a bunch of new events and
new sights and sounds and as it's going
by that is prospectively it seems to be
flying by in retrospect however maybe
the next day or you're back on vacation
looking back upon that and it seems to
be a long day
so retrospectively it seems that it was
an extended period of time and this is
something that was pointed out as far
back as William James and his and his
principles of neuroscience over 100
years ago and the point is is that
retrospectively we're not so much
telling time but were rebuilding or
estimating how much time has elapsed
based on the number of experiences we
have in memory so retrospectively or
more estimating how much time has
elapsed if there was a period of full of
new memories then you're left with
impression that it was a long period of
time retrospectively but prospectively
as it was taking place you were paying
at
to some sort of internal clock in our
brain in which you were looking at or
querying that was telling you that not
much time has elapsed because you
weren't paying much attention to time so
on the other hand when you're very bored
or in an anxious state people experience
time as dragging or going slow again
prospectively you're very anxious you're
waiting to hear from somebody who you
know is at the hospital or you just got
important telephone call and you're
waiting for somebody to call you back
and time seems to drag it seems to be
going slowly because of course
prospectively you're attending to time
you're very you're at the airport their
planes delayed you're very bored and
you're waiting for it for news about
whether you're going to make your trip
or not and then you find out it's going
to be in six hours
you're now you're just in sort of this
this unhold mode in which time seems to
be dragging going very slowly
prospectively you look back on that and
that's merely a blip in time there's
because retrospectively there's not many
items in your memory there's nothing
particularly exciting about visiting the
plant Airport bathroom for the first
time so that's doesn't stick in your
memory so you're left with this feeling
retrospectively at that time actually
was not very long-lasting so you have
this paradox in which retrospectively
times seem to have not occupied much of
your your conscious experience but
prospectively you were aware of the
dragging